one of the uh top head coaches of one of
the top teams in all the land it is
march it is the first of march
so it is time for madness to begin and
uh we appreciate the uh head coach of
baylor basketball
scott drew calling into the rich eisen
show how are you coach man i'm doing
great and you're right
nfl news is super but it's march madness
time so it's basketball time
excellent and i appreciate you uh not
sitting here saying oh gosh
i agree to do the rich eisen show and
then we automatically lose our first
game of the year and you don't hold it
against me so i greatly appreciate that
coach
sounds like you're very well the other
the other thing is i know you're awful
i can see the smile actually through the
phone with michigan jump
jumping leaping over us today at number
two
well as you know it's just uh it's just
a number right now and it's how you do
over the next few weeks right
i mean uh hey spoken like a coach i like
that yeah
well it's because you know what i i i
don't like spiking anything
uh basketball football until obviously
the the work is done
and certainly in this year you know what
i'm saying anything can happen and man
what a journey you guys have already
been on this year
seven postponements four canceled games
you've got three in the next
six days to make up for a lot of that i
mean how how has this year been for you
to coach coach drew well first and
foremost i think every coach out there
has really worked well together trying
to put together games
that normally wouldn't be able to happen
because we wanted our guys to have an
opportunity to play
and all they were sacrificing and
for the game they love to represent
their schools
uh really hats off to the coaches out
there that made games happen
in the non-conference and then when
things opened up in conference and
they're able to fulfill games
and then uh i i think every coach will
tell you uh been amazed with just how
much
our young people have all sacrificed and
uh um
their attitudes and what they've uh uh
done this year and
and uh quite frankly i mean when games
get cancelled
uh they're they're positive and upbeat
all right coach what's next i mean
uh uh they're not holding they're not
pouting and it's a
a situation where they're just thankful
to be playing games and
uh i know that's that's always a joy
when you're around
uh guys that are gonna be future leaders
of this country
and they can handle adversity and
success and then of course you know what
happened in the state of texas
uh statewide just a couple of weeks ago
how'd that affect
what was going on with you your program
uh with the the power going out water
now
we were blessed because yeah we were
blessed because
uh our players were all good but the
staff on the other hand we had
about half our staff without uh power
and uh
electricity so it was it was it was it
was tough from the standpoint
uh uh fireplaces were the where the
heating mechanism
uh one of our coaches was cooking uh uh
his food in the
in the fireplace for the family and uh i
know
i i know you talk about a once in a 100
year pandemic you throw in
uh once in a uh 100-year snowstorm and
you know in texas we get any snow we
don't have the snow plows
no shovels ice scrapers i mean
everything shuts down and uh with with
the frigid temperatures i mean
walgreens uh grocery stores were empty
you had uh uh drugstores were shut down
hospitals weren't doing surgeries or
anything i mean it was it was everything
was
uh uh for four or five days uh on
lockdown basically
scott drew baylor basketball head coach
here on the rich eisen show and
obviously with your team
having to get i guess conditioning back
and gain preparedness back after a
covert break
uh the last place to try and get back to
speed would be i guess
uh uh the fog island field house on
senior night where they have not lost i
think in 40 years
or something like that so uh how do you
assess your team
entering march right here coach well
well the great the great thing is when
you get into
to to march the teams that are going to
be in the ncaa tournament
are just like the teams we're facing now
i mean uh like you said at kansas uh
on senior night that doesn't get harder
than that and then
we're at west virginia they're ranked
six in the nation and coach huggins done
a phenomenal job with this group
and then we finish up with oklahoma
state
and texas tech and coach boynton and
coach beard have done
outstanding jobs with their groups and
so that's a uh
6 17 and 18 in the nation if that
doesn't get you ready for
march madness i don't know what will
right and then the plans for
for indianapolis where you'll be all
bubbled up have you gotten
some sort of protocols already in hand
because you know
obviously your place is secured how long
you stay there is
is obviously going to be on you and your
coaching staff but
what's that procedure like right now for
you coach as you go through everything
well i i don't know all the details but
from what i
what i recollect and what i what i what
i know
is our conference tournament is
basically trying to do the exact same
thing
to keep us safe number one uh and then
number two to prepare us for when we go
to indianapolis so
uh one thing i i tell you every coach
really appreciates is
uh dan gavit is him and his group who
worked really hard
uh he does a great job uh uh providing
information
uh with uh usually the andy katz
interviews and then
he's very accessible to coaches with the
committees he's on
trying to make sure that he takes our
input and uh
i think uh everybody after last march
not having an ncaa tournament
is going to be really really excited for
this one scott drew here on the rich
eisen show boy coach
i mean you've coached in everything huh
um how you got
you know into the the gig uh in baylor
uh with the scandal uh
with coach bliss before you uh and how
you were able to
manage and navigate this program uh out
of that and into
uh success during a pandemic um
how often do you have you leaned on your
dad on on homer to get
just how long do how often do you do
that well
well the good thing is uh uh um during
season especially
uh there's nothing better than having a
hall of fame uh uh
dad who's there to give you advice it
knows uh first and foremost
um what to say how to say it because he
knows how you're feeling
and uh uh that's been a true blessing
and then obviously my brother
uh bryce does the same for me but but i
mean we
we we've gone through stuff that uh i
mean there is no book going through a
pandemic there's
uh you're you're um snowstorm or the
only school to ever not have a
non-conference i mean so there's a lot
of firsts
uh that our program's gone through and
at the same time
couldn't be more proud of where we're at
uh and
um what the what the teams have
accomplished throughout the years so
uh this year has been uh a year like no
other
and uh when it's all said and done um i
can tell you
again every coach can be really thankful
that uh the players sacrificed what they
did to make this year possible for all
college basketball what's your first
basketball memory coach what is that uh
my dad
uh taken me recruiting when he was an
assistant at lsu
and i think it was probably two in the
morning we got pulled over
for speeding and i remember it was so
cool looking at them uh uh
flashing lights and my dad told me
that's really not the
the excitement he was looking for but
anyway that was one of my first
basketball memories is going recruiting
and then
uh seeing the the flashing lights and
being able to uh
see a police officer at a young age like
that then and obviously
you know um when your dad started
coaching at valparaiso
um and it's i imagine that's how you
started getting into the concept of
coaching and playing and things of that
nature
absolutely and and when you have march
madness come along uh
uh one of the most memorable shots is by
your brother 1998
yes uh a great memory valpo over ole
miss
uh in in 2.5 seconds left and
bryce hits the three and there's a great
pass from jamie sykes jenkins with a
great catch and
feeding one of the most memorable shots
and every time i see it i still smile
so that's it that that that that that's
a great thing and
uh love this time of year for college
basketball fans it doesn't get any
better than this
um i tell you that that the toughest
thing is like as you know in the nba
uh playing best out of seven series
usually the best team wins
but in uh march madness with the parody
in college basketball one 40-minute game
anything can happen uh so you got to be
on point and uh
that's why you have so many uh upsets
and exciting times no no
i know you've got exciting times right
here in front of you but i do love
hitting the wayback machine a little bit
here i mean what is it like being the
assistant
uh in a huddle uh with your dad i guess
calling up a play for your brother
to to win a first round game as an upset
in the 13th seat against ole miss what
the heck was that like
for you well i i i i can tell you it was
it was the only time where
um the whole team jumped on the pile now
the coaches were smart and we went on
the very top
but
pandemonium and for for for me
personally it was such a special group
because obviously my brother was a
senior and
i ended up being the 16th pick played
six years in the nba
but that was a special group he came in
with and uh they'd been to the ncaa
tournament
uh several times and knocked on the door
but hadn't uh broke through
and then to finally break through and
get that win and then i get uh
i get a little longer coaching my
brother and and that great class uh
98 in fact uh one of our assistants on
our baylor staff
jared nunes um the guard on that team as
well and
he's done a great job great job here
with us and uh whenever
that highlight comes on he makes sure he
points out that
that was that was the team he was on i
love that that's so great now it wasn't
a moment in the huddle like hoosiers
where your dad was using your brother as
uh as a decoy and your brother and
everyone looks at your dad like what are
we doing here
okay and your brother and your brother
said i can make the shot that that
wasn't like the movie all right
well actually it was one of those
situations where the play was called on
the court because
um we were out of time out so uh it was
probably
that
you know dad always knows best because
me and my brother always were like why
do we practice this place so much we
never use it yeah
really just no kidding
so do your kids now say to you how come
we're constantly practicing this play
and you're like absolutely
absolutely you never know when you're
gonna need it
show them one of the greatest moments of
the of the history of march madness
as right as an example absolutely
absolutely that is so cool okay
so so i guess what is how do you
approach it
i mean you you've got such a great shot
here you've got a great team here
you got a team with a bunch of uh a
bunch of can do want to
thinking they can do it so how do you as
a coach
negotiate this navigate this knowing the
opportunity
that's sitting here right in front of
you on march first well i think every
every coach is pretty somewhere
in the standpoint uh and that is you
can't you can't look at the big picture
it's one game at a time
and it's one play at a time and
everything you've done
throughout the course of the season
that's that's what you're going to
continue to do
and you can't get wrapped up where the
moment becomes too big
so uh with us we're really uh blessed we
got a real mature group
um we we have a group that uh uh uh
basically for two straight years has
been ranked in the top five
um and and has dealt with uh
expectations dealt with pressure and at
the same time been able to uh
continue to put the team first and uh
play for each other
and because of that uh uh we've been
successful and hopefully
that gets you no guarantees um but uh
defensively we've been one of the top
teams in the country the last two years
offensively the last i looked we were
fourth on ken palm
uh prior to the fog um but i i can tell
you that uh
at the end of the day you're not always
gonna make shots so you better be good
uh defensively and you better be good on
the glass and uh
we're normally good on that uh the other
night in kansas we weren't we give
kansas a lot of credit for that
um but uh the the team that we've had
for two years is good in those two areas
now i i asked this last question
of you uh with the risk of sounding
stupid and dumb but it is something that
a lot of people
who are who observe think that
a loss like the one you just suffered is
helpful
that pressure is removed that you don't
have an undefeated sort of pressure to
keep it
going that you do sometimes learn from
adversity and and
a loss would you agree with that
assessment
coach oh i i i can tell you hindsight
tells you that the
uh uh everyone that's won a national
championship since indiana
has had a loss so i would tell you that
that's that's a
that's a that might not be a bad thing
getting a loss at the same time there's
no coach that feels good with the loss
nor do they want a loss and if you have
a team that uh
likes losing or is okay with it you're
probably not very good
so uh now we're all miserable right now
but uh at the same time
we've been blessed it's our first loss
since uh uh
last march so uh um if you can go a year
without a loss
uh i think you're doing you're doing
pretty well and how about the kids that
had
you know that obviously that have uh
were on a team like last year
and then march madness due to the
pandemic ripped out from under them
they must be so fired up right now they
must be they they must be out of their
minds
that they did not have an opportunity
last year and now they're about to get
it
in a bubble yeah so so that that's been
a blessing because some teams
uh um lost a lot of guys and and and i
feel for our seniors that uh
freddie gillespie devonte bandu oleg
that didn't get a chance to play
in march but at the same time we
returned a lot of guys and a lot of
guys came back to college because they
wanted to play in march and
um uh have a chance to be a part of the
ncaa tournament
as we all know it's a uh growing up it's
a it's something that
you dream of it's uh uh something you
can remember the rest of your life and
even
if we don't have all the fans all the
hoopla all the media and all that that
the kids get to experience
um they still are gonna uh at the end of
the day know that they played in uh uh
uh part of the ncaa tournament what a
great memory for them and
uh hopefully it's one that uh uh we
could see michigan and us in the final
four
i'm good with that you're good with that
i will i will sign for that sir
i will sign for that sir and uh the
usual thing that i hope of my guest the
rich eisen show bump
um that i'll be a bit conflicted on that
day but i think you'll
you'd understand that right i i i
definitely understand it so as long as
we don't play michigan just cheer for
the bears
coach scott drew thank you for the call
really appreciate it this was fun i hope
uh i hope you uh have an outstanding
march it goes as well as you hope
appreciate you thanks for your time you
bet that scott drew head coach of baylor
basketball
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here